according to a Gallup poll only 48% of
American parents are completely or
somewhat satisfied with the quality of K
through 12 education their children are
getting educator and entrepreneur
Sal Khan is working to bring free
education to the world he's the founder
of Khan Academy a nonprofit organization
that offers free educational content
online in instructional videos on topics
like math biology and grammar that helps
students develop their skills and
provide teachers with tools Khan
Academy's online platform has 64 million
registered users in 190 countries last
year alone it benefited some 140,000
teachers worldwide Sal Khan good morning
morning
so Khan Academy is announcing something
called mastery learning what is that and
how can I get some it's a it's an old
idea it's arguably the first way that
people learned that hey if you need to
learn something if you're having trouble
with it keep working on it until you
master it and then you go to a more
advanced concept but in the education
systems that all of us grew up in we all
learned at the fixed paced and if you
talk to most teachers say their seventh
grade teacher they'll see that some of
their kids are operating at a
fourth-grade level and some are
operating in an eighth grade level but
the teacher has to teach to the middle
and leaving some behind and leaving some
bored and so the idea of mastery
learning is just that no let's allow
every student to learn at the right
level and that if they're having trouble
with something fill in those those gaps
it's just until now it was hard to do
logistically how does one teacher with
30 students meet the needs of every
student and that's where we try to come
in give an example of mastery learning
in a subject or something and it could
be in anything it mastery learning in
math if you are having trouble with
negative exponents or say negative
numbers and you get you take a test in
the current system you get a C on that
test you didn't know 20% of the material
then a class will go on to the next
concept where they might use negative
numbers in in a formula so I'm kind of
like well how am I supposed to learn
that if I didn't learn the the previous
concept well and mastery learning if the
first time you got an 80% we'll learn it
a little bit better and keep going for
it it's the way you would learn a
musical instrument or or sport or
whatever else and by contrast if you're
alive for math and you love it then you
can go work on your own
and outpaced the class if this is
something that really fascinates you has
there been a situation where you've
gotten some feedback this has actually
worked in practice yeah well there's
actually decades of research well before
Khan Academy came on seeing that that
works a Benjamin bloom famous with his
to Sigma study where if someone learns
in a mastery framework the kid who was
average ends up being in the 80th or
90th percentile it's just there's no
practical way of doing it
now that we've been out there you know
we have a school district in
Philadelphia recently saw that when
students spend one week one class period
per week doing mastery learning they've
lost 30% more gain than expected which
is a big number I'm for one class I
think it was 30 minutes a week they were
doing it and it's common sense because
these kids were being you know they were
kind of being moved ahead with while
having gaps in some more fundamental
things you know a lot of times when kids
have trouble with algebra or
trigonometry has nothing to do with the
subject matter has nothing to do with
their you know innate intelligence
it's just that they had some gaps in
elementary school that they never got to
fill in really I wish I would have known
that when I was in mr. forgetteth class
it was a problem but let's talk about
her too late it's never too late for
this yeah let's talk about the Khan Lab
School in California that goes all
year-round with short summer breaks have
you found that there's an advantage in
the summer if you found that it's an
advantage for kids to have a shorter
school summer to have a shorter summer
yeah so you know there's Khan Academy
and then we started the separate school
to really understand well now that all
this technology exists how can we change
what a school is all about how can we
make it more human so in and in the lab
school we have which is literally
underneath our offices the teachers are
helping students through mastery
learning and as you mentioned it's
full-day full-year and what that does it
just creates more time and space for
learning you know there's well
documented this notion of a Summer Slide
where over summer not only do kids not
learn for three months but they tend to
forget the previous three months of
school so it's really you having to make
up for six months yeah so so you you you
make up for that fact you know if you
look at Pisa rankings of you know the US
versus other countries a lot of it
actually can be accounted for just by
the the number of school days and we
should say you're still a nonprofit
organization remember when you started
this years ago to help your little
cousin and you're still nonprofit after
all
oh yeah no we're nonprofit as I was you
know I don't own Khan Academy I know as
much of it as you do know we're
supported by you know hundreds of
thousands of people donating money No
well congratulations on doing another
thing that helps us master learning that
could help with the Summer Slide I want
to go do some myself
Thank You Sal always good to see he's
going to likewise